guided by science a new variant but
familiar advice from the united states
if you're not vaccinated get vaccinated
get boosted if you are vaccinated
continue to use the mitigation methods
namely masks avoiding crowds in poorly
ventilated spaces choose outdoors rather
than indoors keep your distance wash
your hands test and isolate if
appropriate there are no signs of the
variant in the us but other countries
are stepping up measures to stop it
spreading in japan for example all
foreign nationals have been banned from
entry that'll last a month and traveling
japanese citizens and residents will
have to quarantine for 14 days on
returning to the country
many nations have already banned
travelers from south africa that won't
stop the spread says the world health
organization we are trying to warn the
other country of of the emergency that
might be that meant that be coming
through and those countries they're
gonna now try to also to try their level
best to pre get prepared
of if should this particular pathogen
enter into their child what are they
supposed to do but closing the borders
obtaining to certain countries for
entering i don't think it's an answer
global stock markets have taken a hit
since the new variant was announced but
analysts say it's short-term shock
we do look for the economy to pick up
again especially spending on services in
the first quarter and going into
the spring the northern hemisphere
spring in the second quarter and beyond
that we look for above average growth
next year public health experts say that
it'll be two to four weeks before
they'll know just how severe the
omnicron variant is
and whether or not the current vaccines
can stop it
alan fisher al jazeera washington